signify
unlock the next configuration the things
that is so unique about Hellraiser and
sets it apart from other horror films is
the existence of the Santa bites they
come from the seams of our reality
this horror film had its own legacy of
movies before it that were around this
mythology were around this iconic
presence of for us I was really
impressed with what they've done just to
have the racial diversity and the lgbtq
plus diversity
cenobites are repulsive and glamorous
horrific but also beautiful fans of the
franchise really come to appreciate all
the many layers that exist enough
is a myth
cenobites have always Advanced design in
the horror space I'm excited for modern
audiences that aren't familiar to
discover them for the first time I hope
that the old fans feel like we've done a
good job and I hope that the new fans
are like oh my
it was really a joy and an honor for me
to visualize some of Clive's creations
and some of our own that may coexist
[Music]